Earlier we saw that screen readers
will announce an element's role, name,
state and
value not necessarily in that order.
By using the bright semantic element,
we've got role, state and value covered,
but we also need to make sure that we're
making elements name discoverable.
This is actually the very first
item on web aims checklist,
provide text alternatives for
any non text content.
At this point, I'm going to take
a quick tangent on technology.
We're in the unfortunate position
of having all of these terms.
Each of which is overloaded in
its own particular way in HTML,
which are also used in various contexts
to refer to the same central concept
we're talking about in this lesson.
Since the way the term label is used in
HTML is closest to what we mean here for
the rest of this course,
I'm going to refer to label
interchangeably to
refer to this concept.
But please keep in mind that in
the context of role, name, value, and
state, the name means the same thing.
With that out of the way,
let's talk a bit about labels.
Broadly, there are two types of labels.
Visible labels,
which are used by all users to
associate meaning with an element, and
text alternatives which are only used
when there's no need for visual labels.
Or here we've got an image that is
self-explanatory to anyone who can see
the image.
By its very nature a text alternative
is usually not visible on the page.
So in this case, we can see this
image of bees swarming, an assistive
technology user would simply have
access to this bee swarming label.
The checklist provides a list
of recommendations for
how to create visible and
non-visible labels.
The easiest is this one.
Form buttons have a descriptive value.
A button typically has
some text content,
and that acts as the button's
text alternative.
Since this text is visible to both sided
users and technology, we're lucky,
because we don't need to do any more
work to create a good experience
versus to technology uses.
So that's an easy one to check off.
Next we need to check that form
inputs have associated text labels.
When we create a form input like a check
box and just put some text next to it,
we get a visual label, but
we didn't actually create
a programmatically accessible label for
the element we're trying to label.
Also, we don't get the nice behavior
where we can click on the label to total
the check box.
We can fix this by
using a label element.
We can either wrap the input element
like this, or we can use the for
attribute on the label.
If we do that we need to make sure
to give the input element an ID and
use the same ID as the value of the for
attribute.
That creates an association
between the label element and
the input element,
whichever these two methods to use,
we will get an accessible label for
the check box, and
we'll be able to total the check
box by clicking the label.